straight ahead on law and crime daily
grand jurors speak in the case involving
the police shooting of briana taylor
should all of the officers have been
charged was the case
properly handled turn yourself in kill
yourself
or do what you need to do a news anchor
leaves a threatening message for a mayor
which lands her under arrest and the
mayor out of office
prosecutors and defense attorneys face
off in a zoom hearing as the case of the
accused parkland shooter
moves forward the judge weighs in i
think my hands are tied when it comes to
your request long crime daily covers
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law on crime
daily i'm erin keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin
grand jurors are speaking out in the
police shooting death of brianna taylor
they're doing so after a court ruled
they could finally speak freely
not cloaked by the secrecy normally
afforded to grand jury proceedings
kentucky attorney general daniel cameron
said the officers who shot and killed
briana taylor
could not be charged under kentucky law
because their actions were self-defense
the officers were executing a no-knock
warrant of course taylor's boyfriend
grabbed his gun and fired the plane
closed officers fired back
shooting and killing brianna her killing
sparked protests and calls for reform
especially considering
the police were really after briana
taylor's ex-boyfriend
in the ruling that the jurors could
speak a judge said kentucky
law and the u.s constitution do not
require complete secrecy
surrounding grand jury materials this is
a rare and extraordinary example of a
case where
the historical reasons for preserving
grand jury secrecy
are null the judge wrote those reasons
include because
officer brett hankinson has already been
indicted and there's little risk of
witness tampering the judge said
immediately after the jurors were
allowed to speak they spoke
law and crimes brian buckmeyer is here
now with some of their statements brian
aaron so under kentucky law a grand jury
must be called to serve at least
once every four months but its members
cannot be called to meet
more than 20 days one person on the
grand jury said the brianna taylor case
was unlike
all others in a statement grand juror
number one took aim at the attorney
general saying
after hearing the attorney general
daniel cameron's press conference
and with my duty as a grand juror being
over my duty as a citizen compelled
action the grand jury was not presented
any charges other than the three wanton
endangerment charges against detective
hankinson
the grand jury did not have homicide
offenses explained to them
the grand jury never heard anything
about those law
self-defense or justification was never
explained either
questions were asked about additional
charges and the grand jury was told
there would be none because a prosecutor
didn't feel they can make them stick
the grand jury didn't agree that certain
actions were justified
nor did it decide the indictment should
be the only charges
in the brianna taylor case the grand
jury was not given the opportunity to
deliberate on those charges
thanks a lot brian that statement comes
as one of the officers involved
in the botch raid on briana taylor's
apartment is also speaking out
here to tell us about that side of the
story is lawn crime daily's terry austin
terry
yeah sergeant jonathan mattingly sat
down for an interview with abc news and
louisville's courier journal newspaper
mattingly says he remembers officers
announcing themselves
at least three times mattingly was one
of the three officers who opened fire he
was wounded by a gunshot to his leg
police say there's no body cam of the
incident but a responding officer's body
cam
captured the chaotic moments as
mattingly collapsed to the ground
outside taylor's apartment here's
mattingly's response
when asked about nationwide protests
it's not a race thing like people want
to try to make it to be this is a point
where we're doing our job
we gave too much time when we go in i
get shot we return fire
this is not us going hunting somebody
down this is not kneeling on the neck
this is nothing like that and i know i'm
i'm not
gonna sit here and act like playing the
big victim card but i mean i was a
victim in this as well
my family has been a victim in this they
have had to go in hiding they have had
death threats
when somebody sits back from their
mansion and accuses somebody they don't
know of being a racist
and and being a dirty cop and being a
murderer
when that's not the case that that does
affect you
you were called racist are you racist no
not at all
appreciate the updates there terry bryan
and joining especially right now is
former prosecutor bernardo violona so
bernarda glad to have you on the
law and crime daily broadcast as usual
the grand juror if we can go back to
that a little bit is really throwing the
attorney general under the bus here do
you think the prosecutors who handled
this case
before the grand jury made a big mistake
or
should it just be allowed to go on this
way thank you for having me aaron aaron
the reality is
is that there was a huge miscarriage of
justice in this case
your role as a prosecutor is to pursue
justice not merely conviction in this
case
a prosecutor has the obligation of
candor and good
faith that was not done here in the
commonwealth of kentucky
that did not take place attorney general
cameron
did this to himself and with that he
really put a detriment to the criminal
justice system
because now the people of kentucky and
also the people that are watching all
around the country
have now lost faith in the criminal
justice system they have lost faith
in the prosecutors to try to trust and
believe that what are they doing
is the right thing and unfortunately
this is going to have
devastating effects all around the
country because of the missteps and the
mishaps of
daniel cameron in this case you know
maybe they also gained faith in the
judge who
allowed these grand jurors to release
the information because now we have
actual facts we can
sit here and discuss terry i want to
move to you now it's interesting that
these jurors were allowed to talk
considering prosecutors in kentucky
pointed to the police shooting of
michael brown in ferguson missouri
and there the grand jurors were not
allowed to talk what's your assessment
of the opposite outcomes
as far as letting the grand jurors speak
you know i think those are two different
cases you might remember that the
michael brown case was the case where
protesters were saying
hands up don't shoot because he was
running away then he turned around
but the grand jury there was given a ton
of evidence it was
extensive and the prosecutor was really
forthright in front of the grand jury
the other difference i think here is
that the department of justice itself
investigated and they also came to the
conclusion
that no charges should have been brought
here and that police officer was cleared
so it's a difference
in the way as bernardo was saying the
evidence
was presented here everything was there
not as much
that's a great explanation so brian
what's your reaction to the mattingly
interview there
yeah it's interesting i'm not sure if i
was the defense attorney would have had
the officer come forward
but again it's a lot of softball
questions are you racist no i don't
think he's racist i agree with him
and to some degree he is a victim i have
more issues with the process
rather than the individual who's being
prosecuted here because the process
obviously
seems to be lacking for black women in
this country so the process
for instance of how they execute these
no knock warrants the execution of the
kn
knock warrant the investigation into the
case the work of attorney general
daniel cameron that's my issue not
really hankinson in this case
this has been a great discussion but we
have to move on now because still ahead
on law and crime daily we'll take a look
at how actor bill cosby looks behind
bars as he prepares to appeal his sex
crimes case
also the police shooting of jacob blake
set off protests in kenosha wisconsin
but a criminal trial against blake on a
different set of accusations is moving
forward
we'll break down the case right after
this
[Music]
a new prison mug shot of bill cosby has
his fans and friends
concerned take a look cosby is smiling
but looks disheveled with messy hair in
the prison photo
the 83 year old comedian is serving time
for felony sex assault
cosby's publicist released a different
photo taken during a virtual
visit to assure his fans that he's doing
okay during the pandemic
the pennsylvania supreme court has
agreed to review two
issues in cosby's case the man at the
center of protests against law
enforcement in wisconsin appeared
remotely for a court hearing
jacob blake was shot seven times by a
kenosha police officer
officers were responding to a call from
a woman saying her boyfriend was at her
home
and that he wasn't supposed to be there
blake is recovering from his injuries at
a rehab facility in illinois he's
pleaded not guilty to charges of third
degree sexual assault
criminal trespass and disorderly conduct
he appeared in court via zoom for a
pre-trial hearing
there also was a state's motion for
admission of
other acts which they claim
[Music]
are attributed to the defendant
involving other acts of
violent attacks on the complaining
witness in the case
on other occasions um
what's the status of the case right now
judge at this point the case is
unresolved
from the defense perspective we had
received that motion yesterday
so i'm asking the court to allow me
about a week to
respond in writing we have had some
discussions about potential resolution
but we don't have
a resolution to present to the court i
believe that mr
wiedenfeld and i wish to continue those
discussions and
we have a joint request for the court to
not hold a ludwig hearing at this point
and hold open the possibility of
resolution
blake's case is scheduled to go to trial
on november 9th the judge is giving both
sides the opportunity to resolve it
before then so brian
the state filed a so-called other acts
motion that they were talking about
there that involves alleged violent acts
on the
complaining witness or the victim
explain that process to me and should
these other acts come into this trial
so without knowing exactly what those
acts are i can't really go too deep into
it but
the fact that it's against the same
complaining witness or victim as you're
putting it does give it a strong chance
to show that there is either a lack of
mistake
or that this is uh the defendant's mo
and those are
really good grounds to bring in previous
bad acts or previous bad crimes
so bernard this case predates the
shooting itself which of course made the
national headline so the question is
should anything about the shooting come
into this trial
so aaron there's so much that we don't
know about this case and also about the
shooting itself
where mr blake was shot seven times in
the back
so not knowing that it'll be difficult
to tell because
one the county has been very tight-knit
as to what information they're going to
release to the public
so my only concern i guess at this point
is to make sure
that whoever is prosecuting mr jacob
blake and i believe it is the kenosha
county district attorney's office has to
have
a different prosecutor or different
prosecutor's office to do the
investigating
investigation into the shooting of jacob
blake so there
is no conflict that exists or appearance
of a conflict
yeah and that appearance is the key word
because even if there is no true one
there's always the possible appearance
and that's why we try to keep these
things separate
terry the trial in this case is coming
up on november 9th it's only a couple of
weeks away
there were additional rallies and
protests one might say
surrounding the shooting uh so so this
is really in the news locally
how do they see the jury i think that
what is going to happen here is we're
going to see a resolution of the charges
against jacob blake because the fact
that he was shot seven
times in the back i don't think that
anyone wants to bring this
domestic assault case against him
because
clearly there was excessive force used
against him so
i think we might see a resolution of
those charges before we see a resolution
of
the charges against the police officer
it's highly possible and of course we
saw the judge trying to spur that on in
that little hearing so many nuggets in
these pre-trial hearings they
tip the hat to what's going to happen in
the trial and still to come on our
broadcast here on law and crime daily
the alleged parkland high school shooter
is back in court
and there's another delay in the case
we'll explain that plus
a profanity-laden tirade for an alaska
mayor lands a news anchor in legal
trouble
our analysis of that that viral
recording
is straight ahead
allegations of sexting and an
anti-semitic voicemail led the mayor of
anchorage alaska to resign and the saga
ends with the arrest
of a tv news anchor mayor ethan
berkowitz resigned last week after
admitting to sexting with anchor maria
athens athens posted a photo of what
appeared to be berkowitz naked to her
facebook page
and accused him of sex crimes here's the
profane voicemail the news anchor left
for the mayor
and we've had to beep out a lot of
swearing
ethan it's maria atkins from fox abccw
newsnet national alaska
i just learned through my uh emmy
award-winning journalism
you're also a pedophile in like little
girls and children
and there's a website i'm so exposing
you
i'm gonna get an emmy so you either turn
yourself in
kill yourself or do what you need to do
i will
personally kill you and mara kimmel
myself
you peace of living
you have met your max mother you have
met
your mother max i can't believe i am
such a good person and thought i loved
you i
hate i don't even hate you i will pray
for your
you peace loser and
i'm putting this on the news tonight bye
have a great friday you
motherfu
wow police charge maria athens whose
voice you heard there with assault
criminal mischief and disorderly conduct
after she attacked her boss identified
who
is also her boyfriend police say she
also attacked an officer when they tried
to arrest her
okay terry austin what do you think
i think i have not heard a string of
words
like that put together in the long time
and i hope she doesn't eat with that
dirty mouth
i think these charges are not going to
go away i think
it's going to go to trial because her
threats were of a very serious
nature and if the jury hears even
part of that tape i think they're going
to hold her accountable
for her horrible words yeah
i mean this doesn't look good to a jury
brian um
when you say i will personally kill you
and you leave it in a recorded message
what's the defense i have to ask what's
the defense you're the defense attorney
what is it
can i get a plea you know why
terry wants the trial you want uh so
this is hard because
under any interpretation of a threat
it's a true threat it's immediate
it's not conditional the only thing i
would say is that
at the end of the day it is a fairly low
level crime
this is something that i think at least
in new york and possibly in alaska that
you don't typically see
go to trial it's something that's
negotiated the thing hey she needs anger
management she needs counseling she
needs something let's not put her in
jail i think that's the argument here
yeah terry i don't think you'd be
offering that plea agreement you want to
see the trial
i do want to see the trial because you
can't just go around saying i'm going to
kill you she should know better she's a
reporter and she's been on television
she should not
leave messages like that i think it's
horrible
taking the words right out of many of
our mouths terry austin brian buckmeyer
well when we come back the case of the
accused parkland school shooter
arguments are moving very slowly forward
for the man accused of killing 17
students
at a high school building an update on
yet another delay in the case
in just a moment to wrap up now with the
case of the accused parkland school
shooter
defense attorneys for nicholas cruz say
they're unable to have a psych
evaluation to their client because the
jail is closed to outside visitors due
to covid19 precautions
cruz is facing the possible death
penalty if convicted of murdering 17
people at marjory stoneman douglas high
school
his attorneys say an evaluation via zoom
is just not sufficient
court records show more than 1 000
people are on the witness list
potentially
to be called at trial the defense is
asking for a good
faith witness list to try to narrow down
that number
a request the state is objecting to
gerar that is uh ridiculous the law
doesn't call for that
we list the a witnesses and the sea
witnesses
they've even requested of us to take
deposition of the sea witnesses
we agreed uh there they have provided
139
witnesses themselves we don't know who
they're going to call
our our obligation is to provide
information uh as the witnesses who know
something
about the case and that's what we have
done as they even point out in their
requests
there is no law demanding that we do
that
and we're being as thorough as we can we
don't know who they're going to call
they haven't even provided us uh you
know who their
defense is going to be if they're going
to rely on mental health
we're just sitting and waiting cruz is
represented by a team of public
defenders they've voiced their concerns
multiple times about the magnitude of
work preparing for what's expected to be
an extremely high profile trial
state has announced ready for trial uh
many many times and i don't
and i'm not we're not suggesting that
there's a law that requires them to
provide us a good faith witness list
what we're asking for
in order to speed our preparation and
prevent us
from wasting hours and hours of our time
as we did already we're just asking that
they tell us we've given them a list of
139 witnesses as mr seth said
they've given us a list of hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of witnesses
and if what they're saying is they're
intending to call every one of them so
be it then we need to prepare for every
single one of those witnesses
and any motion that goes with it but if
they want us to speed our preparation
they can help us in this way cruz's
trial is now delayed indefinitely the
judge is asking both sides to try to
work together
in the meantime i agree with mr satz
there's no law that says i have to
require them to do that even at the time
of trial i can't require them to do that
i can say call your next witness but i i
can't order the state to tell what
witnesses are calling and
and so on and so forth so my suggestion
would be
reach out try to get some kind of
stipulation let them know that the
what you're relying on um
and so on and so forth then maybe a
stipulation can be done before you have
to do all that work but that that's
that's a suggestion obviously it's not
an order
terry i gotta ask about this this issue
about witness lists i see this
being done differently in almost every
single state in some state
the rules of procedure basically require
each side to hand over witness lists
it's done orderly so that each
side can prepare and not be blindsided
and then in other states
it basically turns into a game of
blindsiding the other side with who's
going to get called
it just doesn't seem fair to do it the
second way it seems fair that the
procedure would be set out
or do i just have this all wrong no you
have it all right aaron
i think that both sides should be fair
and reasonable they should give their
witness list
especially the prosecution they have to
give and the motion said a
more realistic witness list because the
defense
does have to you know prepare for the
case and as horrendous as this trial
was as this case was back in 2018
you know cruz does deserve a defense and
the defense
has to prepare so i think asking for a
realistic list
makes sense so they can prepare whatever
motions
and they can defend the case so i i do
agree with the
defense here what i want to see is a
focus on
process and due process fair process and
not just on punishment
even in heinous cases like this brian if
you got deluged with
a thousand names on a witness list how
would you even react to it
i would laugh i would say all right fine
i have a thousand names
now i need to speak to each one of them
i need to do depositions for each one of
them
it's covered right now and i would
highlight the absurdity of what these
prosecutors are doing
similarly to how the defense is doing it
here they're probably a little bit nicer
than i would but it's absurd they should
be a better list
that sounds like a great tactic and
those depositions are possible in
florida we'll see you next time right
here on law and crime daily to discuss
justice in america
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions we break down the
case of a serial killer another day of
drama between both sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the law and crime network is everywhere
and we invite
you inside the jury box this is lawn
[Music]
crime
[Music]
you